[Music]
let's get to holiday gifts
yeah let's do it and then i i have to
run in about 10 minutes so why don't you
go first
sweet i've got a bunch you know we're
getting that time of year where
especially with uh
supply constraints that it's like good
to order on the early side you know for
a lot of this stuff
so i don't know when this is planning on
dropping but these are all for christmas
2022. yeah exactly
so
i'll say a couple things one of the
things that i have found to be a really
fun thing speaking of like ted lasso and
other fun things that you can do at
night that don't involve drinking or
or just you know some some fun things to
do with your spouse or significant other
legos for adults man some of these lego
projects they're not for kids they're
like super
throwback super complicated like crazy
lego sets i just got darya my wife just
had her birthday
she's uh actually her birthday's in
three days but um i just got her the
ecto one because she's a huge
ghostbusters fan oh that's awesome i'm
looking at it right now yeah it's super
legit it's not like snap five pieces
together it's like this is like a you
know thousand piece or whatever it is
project um i got the voltron one which
is uh which is awesome they have a
vintage porsche 911
and and you can link these up but
they're just they're just fun it's just
something you know to when you're at
home and bust out the legos and have a
good time we'll have links to all these
in the show notes so if you're if you're
lucky enough to listen to this on the
early side because i'm sure they're all
sell out
then uh just go to tim dot blog
podcast and search random show and it'll
pop right up there you go um a couple
other quick things from me because i
know you get a bounce
so dude
are you a fan of [ __ ] made knives i am
yes okay cool so i got this new favorite
from them it's the 537 bailout family of
knives like it's just like a sick little
pocket knife it's open assist or what is
it uh this has the little tiny nodule
that you kind of just like flip open
it's not automatic i do have an
automatic that actually like right here
like check this out this you can only
get these in oregon because they're they
they're legal here in oregon but like
you got the full like see you guys on
video if you watch that video yeah but
that's that's organ only edition
um that that's [ __ ] made as well but
benchmade makes great knives for those
of you listening to audio version i just
pulled out a switchblade on the video
but they're legal in oregon so you know
i'm a boy scout so i just i always like
to have a blade on me every eagle scout
needs a switchblade exactly
another pocketknife that
i'm a huge fan of since you mentioned
knives is the
the kershaw ken onion leak serrated
folding knife with speed safe and it has
a
an open assist that is fantastic i like
kershaw really really nice i don't know
if you know this but benchmades are
actually made about a half hour from my
house i went to their factory oh that's
cool yeah and you can take your knives
in and they'll just sharpen them for
free it's really cool you know you
should actually now that i i totally
blanked on this i think he's in
i think he's still near portland but
murray carter who is on my podcast yes
the knife maker who is trained in japan
is
nearby so also if you want to make your
own knife
he could help get you up to speed
carter cutlery right is that right yeah
carter cutlery he's amazing yeah
yeah you can make a neck knife if you
really wanted to go full portland thug
i need to go visit those are great
holiday gifts right there oh those
knives are one of a kind super super
special yeah i can link those up yes
we'll link to this aura has a new ring
out the aura iii it's got real-time
heart rate better sensors full
disclosure i'm an investor but i don't
get anything from saying that it's just
a cooler ring i use the aura for for
sleep so i put on when i go to bed and
it shows me all my sleep stats me too i
used it for sleep as well matt walker
just joined as an advisor and is doing
stuff for them and helping on the
algorithm side so it's cool yeah that's
awesome do you know these stone paper
notebooks did i ever tell you about cars
no i just pulled up the website but i
don't know these guys so imagine like
we all know like moleskine and you know
notebooks are always kind of like a fun
little gift to give people these the
cars notebooks are like the softest
they're made out of stone so it's not
paper they're made of like the stone
composite each page
it's not heavy wait each page is made
out of stone this is what i was trying
to figure out yeah yes they're made of
stone so this is like hipster abe
lincoln
yes pretty much awesome but it it's like
the softest is it's like it's a velvety
type it's it's just a dream to write on
anyway these cars notebooks are
fantastic they're not that expensive
they're they're better than moleskins
how did you find this
somebody gifted me one and i when i put
like pen to paper i was like wow this
feels so good and then i researched them
and realized that they were sustainable
just made from not trees but from stone
and i was like i have to and now i know
i just have them all over the house like
i i buy them i've got two on my desk
right now
how on earth do you slice stone thinly
enough i think it's a pulverized and
they make like a
a sheet out of it
that makes more sense you can click on
the about and then click on the
materials link there and it'll show you
how they do it amazing but uh it's
really really
beautiful to write on oh and then also
do that um
my last gift idea is that venison jerky
that you invested in you got me hooked
on that stuff oh maui nui that stuff's
so good it's so good i keep ordering it
i had a bag right before we recorded
it's the best 10 grams of protein like
you know post workout or whatever just
the easy and it's tasty it's it's really
good oh it's so good so people can can
check that out maui m-a-u-i-nui
n-u-i venison i think it's just maui nui
venison venison.com i get the bars
because they make them in links as well
but i like the bars the best the pepper
bars yeah i love the bars i actually eat
the links more
they have fresh cuts they're used in
some of the top restaurants in the
country they're fantastic so and they're
wild yeah wild harvested yeah wild
harvest so they're not like uh pending
them up or anything that's not they're
gobbling up the ecosystem in hawaii
which is why also
you're actually improving the ecosystems
in hawaii by
eating this deer because the the effects
are so destructive
it's part of the reason i invested i
mean there's aerial footage
of erosion and runoff
damaging and destroying coral reef in
hawaii because the undergrowth has been
so decimated by axis deer yeah you sent
me the video and there's like thousands
of them like oh it's insane it's not
like you're some butterfly where you're
like making extinct like no no no no
they're they're everywhere they are
everywhere
and they're
there it is just about the most nutrient
dance probably the most nutrient-dense
red meat i've ever had in my life it's
it's fantastic so maui nui
i definitely second that
awesome
i'll actually just say
that i just put together
a
10
of my favorite
goodies that make great gifts and i
think let me just check here i think
it's just tim dot blog slash gift guide
and
that'll take people directly to
10 gifts to make your holidays extra fun
relaxing and delicious yeah so people
can just check that out
you